hey
have you read marley and me yeah
sad why is it ted
you don't know what happens no that's
why i'm reading it what does the dog die
at the end no i'm not saying anything
how much i had left
i was thinking you'd come stay with me
it's okay if i tell them we're trying to
get pregnant that's great and i say we
are because it's not sexist that way
right that's what you told me yeah i
can't wait to be the creepy gay uncle
you're hired
well last i heard you moved to l.a to be
an actor yeah you're not here i won an
oscar oh
surprise oh back from the dead what are
you doing here um
when do the boys show up
it's dyke night sweetie it's what
dyke night
you're my brother and we're supposed to
be there for each other i'm tired of you
acting like you're the healthy one and
i'm your special needs kid
i get depressed about my life so i'm not
a famous actor i got news for you no
one's a famous actor george clooney is a
famous actor okay george clooney i guess
that's one exception let me go 10 years
without talking it's probably not worth
talking about now you have to tell me a
secret i slept with my scuba instructor
maggie
wouldn't it be easier just to tell lance
you're not ready to have a kid what am i
gonna do
i told somebody that i was in town don't
freak out
wow
you know what you need to take the edge
off
i say you put on something pretty we're
going out
no matter what
we should have a dude's day i think your
version of dude's day and my version is
totally different
awesome awesome
i have a very serious question for you
mm-hmm
will you go to prom with me
you